now because this middle term gives
itself the form of an outer expression
which is at the same time taken back
into the inner its existence is not
restricted to the immediate organ of the
action the middle term is rather the
movement and form of countenance and
figure in general which take no part in
the action these lineaments and their
movements are according to this notion
the action which is held back and which
remains in the individual and as regards
the individuals relation to the action
really perform they constitute his own
control and observation of the action
expression in the sense of a reflection
on the actual expression the individual
is therefore not dumb as regards his
external action because he is thereby it
once reflected into himself and gives
expression to this reflectiveness into
self this theoretical action or the
individual speech with it with himself
about the external action is also
perceptible to others for this speech is
itself an expression
in paragraph 317 Hagel is again talking
about this middle term that is
constituted by the the organ but in this
paragraph not fully so buy it as we're
going to see there's a very interesting
dynamic that is going on within the
individual and and you know you've got
this whole inner outer middle term as
within the scope of the individual but
but it's good that we remind ourselves
that there's also this sort of
estrangement that is occurring where
what a person is expressing themselves
through or by as the outer to a certain
extent escapes them the action or the
speech that that they they let go into
the world and which then can be
interpreted or reinterpreted by an other
so Hagel begins here by saying this
middle term it gives itself the form of
an outer expression we've seen that
already right which is not at the same
time taking bat which is at the same
time taken back into the inner that's
what we're going to talk about through
the rest of this paragraph what does it
mean for it to be taken back into the
inner how is this this movement outward
not simply a loss of itself or a
constant flow you might say of time of
effort of attention sort of exhausting
what sinner and and gradually
culminating in there being only the
outer so what are the implications of
this he says its existence is not
restricted to the immediate organ of the
action what is the immediate organ of
the action well in the case of speech
we're talking about the mouth we just
talked in the previous paragraphs about
other things like the hand the
handwriting the voice itself we might
expand this to other things as well so
he says the middle term is rather and
he's got kind of an interesting
formulation for this the middle term is
the movement the buffet goon and the
form of as Miller is translating at the
countenance what is the countenance it
is it is the face and the countenance is
not just the face as something purely
passive something that doesn't doesn't
do anything as we might say in a death
mask rather it is the countenance as
showing the person as a reflective of
the inner and then he says figure
Gestalt right or to gestalt tongue
rather the the shape of the thing also
the way in which the parts are are
arranged in in relation to each other so
this is quite important here and he goes
on and he says these don't actually take
part in the action and because they
don't take part in the action they're
not getting lost in the action the
remaining you could say with the the
individual they you know are going to
transfer as we could say from situation
to situation a situation so that is why
we're tempted in physiognomies to look
precisely to these kinds of features so
he goes on then he says these lineaments
and their movements are according to
this notion the action which is held
back so in acting part of what's being
done is what we've already talked about
before the you know the movement into
the outer this is he's going to say
expression right but part of it is being
held back held back for what held back
for the inner of the individual sort of
you know continually retained no he goes
on he said something really interesting
here he says this remains an individual
and as regards the individuals relation
to the action really perform
they constitute his own control and
observation of the action so up until
now we've really been talking about the
the outer the external action as being
something that is sort of thrown out
there and it's supposed to express the
individual more than anything else but
we saw that there were some problems and
some paradoxes with that now we see you
might call it a restoration of a kind of
initiative that has been there the
entire time the the individual is able
to engage in reflection or as Hagel's
has control over the external action now
what does that mean while hagel causes
another kind of expression so really we
have expression occurring in two
different ways and he's going to go on
further and talk about it as also being
a kind of action let's look at this this
paragraph very closely he says what we
have here is expression in the sense of
a reflection on the actual the
expression that has been externalized so
there's an expression that is external
and then there's also an expression that
is internal and all of this is occurring
precisely because of the capacity for
this middle term to be reappropriation
that's what allows them to have this
capacity for engaging in a kind of
control over the action we might think
of this in terms of well if we use the
example of the face right when you do in
action you can signify to other people
for example that you're doing it under
duress that it's not reflective of who
you are or that you're really
anticipating the result of the action
and we we might multiply examples of
this sort of thing so he says the
individual is
not dumb as regards his external action
because he is there by at once reflected
into himself and gives expression to
this reflectiveness into self now Eagle
towards the end of this talks about this
theoretical action or the individuals
speech with himself about the external
action thinking is a kind of
communication within the self we're not
just having pure thought in a certain
way you can say that there's a there's a
premacy that that is not entirely
complete within Hagel but but emerges
from time to time a primacy of the
practical over the merely speculative
the merely theoretical what is it to to
be it is to act it's not just to think
it's to act because thought itself is a
kind of action something that was
recognized but it was not fully worked
out by previous thinkers like say
Aristotle or Thomas Aquinas and so this
thinking to oneself about one's own
actions and it's externalities its
expression is itself a kind of action
within oneself and here's where it gets
really interesting Hagel says that this
can be manifested to another he says
this theoretical action is perceptible
to others for this speech is itself an
expression what speech the interior
speech of thought so already we have the
other being brought back into the
picture in an important way
in this inner therefore which in its
expression remains an inner there is
observed the individual as reflected out
of his actual being and we have to see
what is the significance of this
necessity which is posited in this unity
this reflectiveness is in the first
place different from the deed itself and
therefore can be something other than
the deed and can be taken for something
other we see from a man's face whether
he is in earnest about what he is saying
or doing conversely however what is here
supposed to be the expression of the
inner is at the same time an expression
in the form of immediate being and hence
is itself degraded to the level of mere
being which is absolutely contingent for
the self conscious being it is therefore
indeed an expression but at the same
time only in the sense of a sign so that
the particular way in which the content
is expressed is a matter of complete
indifference so far as the content
itself is concerned in this appearance
the inner is no doubt a visible
invisible but it is not tied to
disappearance it can be manifested just
as well in another way just as another
inner can be manifested in the same
appearance lichtenberg therefore rightly
says suppose the physiognomist ever did
take the measure of a man it would only
require a courageous resolve on the part
of the man to make himself
incomprehensible again for a thousand
years just as in the previous
relationship the given circumstances
were a passive being from which the
individuality took what it could and
want it either submitting to are
transforming that being for which reason
it did not contain them sesa T and
essential nature of the individuality so
here the manifest immediate being of the
individuality is one which either
expresses the fact of its being
reflected out of its actual existence
and is being within itself or which is
for the individuality merely a sign and
different to what is signified therefore
truly signifying nothing for the
individuality it is as much its
countenance as its mask which it can lay
aside the individuality permeates its
shape
moves and speaks in it but this
existence in its entirety equally turns
into a being that is indifferent to the
will and the deed individuality of faces
from it the significance it formerly had
that is of being that in which the
individuality is reflected into itself
or has its true essence instead it
places its essence rather in the will
and the deed
paragraph 318 is quite long and is a
very important transition point away
from some of these reflections that
Hagel has been engaging in about the
human being and his or her action as a
sign of who what you know that person
really is as opposed to say the things
that palmistry is going to look at or
physiognomies and he's moving towards
now letting physiognomies have it say at
least briefly although you notice that
in the middle of this the middle of this
this paragraph he's got this passage
from lichtenberg who he's going to quote
several times in this this entire
section who is an earlier critic of
physiognomies and all the pretensions
that were going along with it Hagel
himself is very deeply critical of it
but he thinks that there's an important
set of you might say negative lessons
that are being learned along the way so
let's let's look at what he says he says
in this inner right we're talking about
the relation to the inner the outer
which in its expression remains an inner
there's this interior ority right there
is observe bulb octant right now and
remember this is the section observing
reason so we're talking about reason
engaging in some observation of itself
of the conscious person and presumably
extrapolating from this to how must be
for for other people as well we're
talking about subjectivity observing
itself at this point so he says the
individual is observed as reflected out
of his actual being his vir click kite
his how he is within the world the world
of others the world as it presents
itself the world of appearance if we
like that there is something lying
behind the appearances that is an in
did you ality that is subjective that
has this this intentional relationship
with itself in its external is a shins
and so Hagel will talk in terms of he'll
use terms like reflectiveness but he's
also talked about reflection as a sort
of attitude or activity expression as
well right and the last paragraph we saw
that this process of thinking about
oneself or taking a stance towards
oneself a reflexive attitude is carried
out as a kind of expression it is an
action and as an action it becomes he
actually said something observable from
the outside by somebody else so now
we're seeing the upshot of this says we
have to see what is the significance of
this necessity which is posited in its
unity now notice he's saying this
necessity is posited he's not saying
that the necessity really is there at
this point but it's something that we
have assumed and now we want to see well
what's going on with that so he goes on
and he says this reflectiveness is in
the first place different from the deed
and Hagel is going to change his
terminology in a way that Miller's
translation doesn't fully capture along
the way cuz you the Miller is using this
term deed to cover both taught which it
works for and also hond lung which it
also works for right so it's not it's
not a terrible error but there there is
a kind of movement within the passage so
he says the reflectiveness is different
than the deed itself the externalize
action and can be taken for something
other now when we're looking from the
outside and a person who's doing
something we don't just see the doing
itself or if we're thinking in terms of
speech or writing we don't just see that
itself now writing is a little bit
different because that can be done at a
distance right so let's put that one off
through the moment just speech and and
the work of the hands I had hon lord so
we see that but we also see the person
and we assume that there is a kind of
what we're going to call motivated pneus
and I'll talk about what that means in
just just a moment the motivated nets to
what they're doing the thing that
they're doing is significant because
they're not just doing it purely at
random or if they are doing something
purely at random like just walking
around and whistling presumably even
that is significant if I've relaxing or
something along those lines right so you
can't really get away from signification
it doesn't necessarily mean every
assumption about the signification is
actually right but we are in a world
that that does have meaningful action
all right so let's go on from there he
says we see from a man's face whether he
is in earnest about what he is saying or
doing this is an important observation
we see in a person's face whether they
are in earnest danced about what they're
saying or doing or at least we think
that we do right that's why we are so
subject to being taken in and sometimes
manipulated because sometimes we mistake
these things or sometimes people are
actually fooling us Hagel is going to
talk later in this passage about the
difference between the face itself and a
mask that is covering it up and the fact
that the human face can in fact become a
mask and there's a little bit of a
digression but this is not something
that is totally unique to human beings
as a matter of fact we see this running
throughout the animal kingdom the
pretence to be something other than what
one is or to dispose of one's body in
ways that that convey
a message different than what one really
means right so territorial fights where
the the the two sparring or in terms of
mating right don't actually try to hurt
each other even though they could very
easily think about box and their antlers
clashing them together be a lot more
rational if they wanted to get rid of
the competition just Gorham right like a
bull Gore's somebody but they don't do
that so they smack these together and
they do that thing and we could go on
and on and on you think about other
animals that are particularly good at a
mimicry and manipulation of their
environment like what is the most
intelligent intelligence of
invertebrates the octopus and we can go
on and on not so is this isn't a purely
human trait but you've got to admit that
human beings have done it for so long
that it makes human interactions much
more problematic in the way that Eagles
talking about here we look at a person
and we can tell whether their earnest
about what they're saying maybe they
really mean it they live a serious
expression they're saying something
angry they look angry they're saying
something sad they actually look sad or
perhaps they say something and they're
joking around with us you know and if we
think about the way a lot of our recent
comedy actually works much of it plays
off of and this is sort of a trait that
runs through comedy at least in the
twentieth and twenty-first century plays
off of that that disjunction it slippage
saying something horrible in a very
upbeat tone of voice with a smile on
your face or doing the the converse
right there that incongruity is a
possibility for us and the question here
then is well should the face be taken as
something purely external no because it
comes with you right it tells you
whether the deed the saying the doing is
really earnest or not
so it's really an expression of this
inner even though it is something outer
he goes out he says conversely what is
here supposed to be the expression of
the inner is at the same time an
expression in the form of immediate
being that is the face just is and it is
a certain way like mine right now right
smiling big smile why am I doing this
just doing it to illustrate a point it's
not the same thing as smiling that way
which you know now that I think about it
actually kind of hurts the cheeks a
little bit when you're totally you know
losing it laughing at something or
thinking a funny thought so he goes on
he says it's degraded to the level of
mere being which is absolutely
contingent for the self conscious being
here's where that that notion of
motivation comes in let me read one more
sentence and then we'll bring that in he
says it's therefore indeed an expression
but at the same time only in the sense
of a sign so that the particular way in
which the content is expressed is a
matter of complete indifference so far
as the content itself is concerned the
face the expression is a sign and for
Hegel when we see this term sign he
means an arbitrary conventional and
therefore contingent sign that could be
a matter of chance a matter of Caprice
it could be a matter of deliberate
deception it could be a matter of
mistaking what the person is actually
showing us in any case we have the
possibility of earnestness or what we
could call the motivated sign right when
the face is showing something that we
take to be a true of the intentionality
inhabiting it them then it is motivated
and when not then it is purely arbitrary
now the problem is
we can't always decide which is which
sometimes we can't even do this with
ourselves you know people who have a
long history of lying to themselves or
concealing from themselves things that
they don't want to face up to they're in
a position towards themselves of the
other some people are forced into
conditions where they have to
dissimulate you don't think about this
if you don't smile you're not going to
keep your job in a situation where jobs
are hard to find you smile all right
because you need to keep that job and
what does that smile mean well that's
just an arbitrary sign in this court in
this case because you wouldn't keep on
smiling like that if you didn't need the
job except that at a certain point you
may in fact keep smiling like that or
you might be doing that just to you son
of a [ __ ] boss I hate your guts right
what was that you said I'm just talking
about how much I love it here you know
we could go on with examples like that
you see that the the possibility of
really showing what is in the inner is
rather attenuated isn't it by the very
fact on how expressive our face can be
or our voice or our hands that are
engaging in actions so he says in this
appearance the inner is no doubt a
visible invisible this is what I had
mentioned several paragraphs before that
we were going to see the visible become
the invisible becoming visible and hegel
talk about it visible invisible they
says but it's not tied to this
appearance what's the invisible the
inner is invisible you can't see my soul
you can't see my personality you can
certainly do inventories if you like if
you're a psychologist but those don't
tell you a hell of a lot why don't you
really get down to it because people as
soon as they figure out what's going on
they give you data that's rather
conflicting sometimes they're useful
quite often for for many people they're
not these days but in any case he says
it can
he manifested just as well as in another
way just as another inner can be
manifested in the same appearance and
here's where he gets to lichtenberg
statement now this is a brilliant thing
that lichtenberg who if you haven't read
before you should you should read him he
is well worth reading he often is read
by people only because of references to
him by other philosophers but he's well
worth reading for his own sake he says
suppose the physiognomist ever did take
the measure of a man it would only
require a courageous resolve on the part
of the man to make him make himself
incomprehensible again for a thousand
years fizzy odd to me is supposed to be
looking at the face or the frame of the
body and deducing how the person really
is what's going on inside of them from
from the outward appearance and then you
know correlating that to what they in
fact do so the physiognomist might think
that there is a frame of the body that
that shows along with a certain facial
cast that this person is dangerous
whereas this person is friendly and
lichtenberg is pointing out well you
know let's see that that somebody
actually does come up with this and
let's say that for for a moment it's
actually true as soon as a human being
finds out that you're doing this sort of
rule rule deducing this they see it as
you try to regulate them and they say
screw you I'm not going to do what you
want me to do I'm not going to conform
to those rules I'm going to be something
different and then the law like
regularity is no longer regularity is it
things become contingent the mere fact
that human beings can do that means that
the whole enterprise is really doomed
from the start isn't it so he says just
as in the previous relationship and what
does he mean by this previous
relationship was that in
previous section the given circumstances
were passive being from which
individuality took what it could and
want it right the things that we're
supposed to be determining a
psychological laws or logical laws we
got to pick and choose what we allow to
affect us as he says for which reason it
did not contain the necessity and
essential nature of the individuality so
here the manifest immediate being of the
individuality is one which either
expresses the fact of its being
reflected out of its actual existence
right the Veer cleat kite and the
reflection out of that into something
inner which is there to begin with and
it's being within itself or for which or
which is for the individuality merely a
sign indifferent to what is signified
what's supposedly signified by the sign
it's not the action right the sign is
supposed to be signifying what is going
on inside of us the smile is supposed to
signify happiness but it could also
signify hatred or I could signify
compliance the you know pensive frowning
face is supposed to convey who knows
what sadness being a deep person being
shallow perhaps you know and it's
because you're your ice cream fell on
the ground when you're an adult you know
you're a kid and your ice cream falls
out that's a tragedy when it falls out
as an adult well that's just a mishap
but you shouldn't be so quite so upset
about that anger you know some people
it's it quite interesting i'll give you
a prime example from my own experience I
used to be very bothered by the fact
that when I would get angry and I
struggled with anger a lot one of the
things that would happen to me was my
you know adrenaline response would kick
in and my hands would shake right and I
thought well that's no good right
because people see your hands shaking
and they're going to assume that you're
actually afraid and then
you probably have to fight them or you
know it's going to be harder to deal
with things or if you are getting angry
and you want them to take seriously the
fact that you're done putting up with
their nonsense having shaking hands is
not going to help you with that turns
out that's not actually the case there
are so many different ways that you can
tell that something really is angry or
not that that's that's that's not that
big of an issue and but there was
something that that I thought now the
shaking hands what does it signify it's
a sign right what interior disposition
does it show well in order to understand
that we probably can't just go by those
signs we're going to have to look at the
outward and what happens and what comes
out of the individuality so he says
here's where we get to this really
brilliant part about masks he says
therefore truly signifying nothing right
for the individuality it is as much its
countenance its face as its mask which
it can lay aside the face is a mask but
the mask is a face how do you tell the
difference well he goes on and he says
the individuality permeates its shape
its frame it moves and speaks in it but
this existence in its entirety equally
turns into a being that is indifferent
to the will and the deed and now here he
doesn't just talk about the deed or the
doing or the behavior he talks about
willing that's villain right and this
doesn't mean the Faculty of will that
would be something interior right this
is what is actually chosen or the act of
choosing as opposed to say the capacity
or the Faculty of choice residing in
there this the Faculty of choice you
can't really see you can maybe do some
things about it by what a person does
you can know about your own faculty of
choice I suppose to some degree but we
can tell
person does in fact will by seeing what
what they actually do what they choose
what they prefer and what they give a
lower priority to that shows us this
when Hagel's calling here the the will
so he says individuality of faces from
it the significance at formerly hand of
being that in which the individuality is
reflected into itself or has its true
essence instead it places its essence
rather in the will and the deep in what
is external now we're actually set up to
start doing some physiognomist thinking
about what it might be like to do some
physiognomies